somehow these elephants are eeking out a
living in a landscape that anyone else
would think is lifeless
conservationist Dr Paula kahunbu spent
her career studying the elephants of
Africa's Lush Savannah grasslands
never laid eyes on a desert elephant
to find out how these remarkable animals
manage to survive in this unforgiving
place
Savannah elephants and desert elephants
are the same species but if you took a
savannah elephant and brought it here it
wouldn't survive
I want to know how these desert
elephants manage to live here
to find one of the constantly roaming
elephant herds Paula has turned to
tracker Hendrick munenbome
and his 25 years of studying the desert
elephant yeah I think someone walked to
yourself
so it's possible we'll find them today
[Music]
is this amazing
I've been watching elephants my whole
life and I've never seen elephants like
these
they may be the same species as Savannah
elephant but you can immediately see the
differences
their legs have less fat on them so they
look taller and their skin is looser
it's incredibly tough for an elephant
here
food and water are both scarce
and it's only getting worse
in the Namib Desert climate change has
brought with it a five-year drought
everything depends on their ability to
get from one Waterhole to the next
there's no time to stop to investigate
to explore to play
it's just survive
survive means keep going keep going
[Music]
thank you